set for his first
season as an hc in the nfl branded
staley of your los angeles chargers how
are you coach
rich great to see you this morning great
to be with you great to have you here um
you must be just all fired up you can't
i mean
we you want to kick this thing off
today i'd imagine right yeah we just had
a great team meeting a little while ago
which you know i wish you could have
kind of zoomed in for that um so back
here at our facility and getting ready
to take on the seahawks this week to
finish off pre-season okay what do you
what are you how are you going to
approach this because as we know uh
preseason is different last year there
wasn't any uh this is the first time
there's just three are you gonna treat
this as the
uh week three dress rehearsal that it
used to be with a four week preseason or
how or not what is your philosophy on
this one we're going to treat it like we
have the first two games we're gonna
make sure that the guys who need to
to compete and define their role within
the team we're going to make sure that
they get every opportunity to showcase
their abilities
and then for the guys who have not
played yet in the preseason that will
still be
the theme for this week
and so looking forward to going up there
against you know pete and their team uh
it'll be a good measuring stick for
these guys that are competing for spots
and um just like we have the first two
games we're going to try to give our
guys a game plan
that allows them to be successful that
gives us a chance to win the game
and that's how we're going to approach
it and hopefully we have three really
good days of practice has herbert
lobbied to get in
he has he he was he was really um he was
really disappointed crushed um
that's why we love him so much um he's
crushed he was he i think he was a
little surprised he was caught off guard
um which again is another great sign
and uh but it's it's been a i feel like
we've really had a productive camp and
we've got three practices this week and
finish it off the right way going up
there to play those guys now i know why
you say it's a great sign but i want you
to verbalize it why do you think it's a
great sign that the unicorn as many of
us referred to him is crushed that he
can't play in pre-season football
justin knows how far he has to go to be
the player he knows that he's capable of
being
and i think that he's got that drive
inside of him
that knows
he can improve
and and so he wants to get as many
chances at improving as possible that's
why he's always the last one to leave
the practice field if you've
taken a look at any of our practices uh
including last week against the niners
he's always the last one to leave the
field and
he's got that refreshing drive that um
all the special players have uh
regardless of the sport and um we really
enjoy you know competing together every
day i know that well i mean he has just
again had such an incredible rookie
season and i know you weren't there for
that
that said i'm sure you're up to speed as
to what maybe he was
uh dealing with uh for the lack of
better phrase in his maturation process
what's different do you think for
him entering this season than last
season when he didn't know he was going
to start and then we all know how he got
thrown in because we're hearing so much
about
sitting and
letting a quarterback sit around and
watch based on the five first rounders
that were taken you don't have to deal
with that but i'm wondering
where you are on this philosophy knowing
herbert what happened with him last year
and how you're getting a quarterback a
little bit more ready in your first year
as the hd yeah i think i think with
justin um you know i think he's going
through a lot of what when you when you
ascend as quickly as he did and i think
under the circumstances too like the
offseason that he had even though he was
a top you know 10 draft pick uh because
of the pandemic and because of the way
the preseason kind of expressed itself
and even during the season i don't think
there is much of the off the field stuff
that is sort of demanded and required of
you as a franchise quarterback and i
think this offseason he got a taste of
that
where
there's all this stuff off the field now
that's coming your way whether it's the
award ceremonies whether it's the media
tour
all the marketing and sponsorships and
there's a lot more people pulling at you
i think off the field and just getting
into his uh routine that way and then
finding out his off-season workout
routine um and and i think that that was
something that you know he was going
through for the first time and i thought
he navigated it really well where
he was giving himself the personal space
that he needed but also putting in all
the work that he knows is required and
and that means so much to him so i think
he found that balance and it is
different you know because you know this
this camp has been different than the
last one i mean after every practice
there's you know several people there uh
asking for a bunch of his time and and
and so that's just part about being a
franchise quarterback and um i think
he's handled it with a lot of grace uh
and humility as you would expect and um
and so i think that part has been
different for him and then i think in
terms of where he's at as a player
there's just two totally different
spaces what he knows uh he's been able
to study so much more
he's been exposed to so much more
offensively defensively situationally he
knows his receivers a lot more i mean i
know that keenan's been kind of quoted
like hey this guy didn't even throw me a
pass last preseason now they've had a
full off season to work together so
i think there's just so many factors
that have contributed to
him being a much more confident player
um a much more prepared player and and
with that being said there's still so
much room uh to go brandon staley head
coach of the los angeles chargers here
on the rich eisen show how much of a
focus is eckler gonna be in your offense
that you're willing to share with us in
front of everybody right now yeah rich i
think speaking specifically from a
defensive perspective
anytime you can activate the running
back and the passing game and you have
to truly defend all five eligible
receivers it is a much tougher cover and
that's what austin forces you to do is
to defend all five eligible receivers
because of his ability as a receiver
both from the backfield and then split
out within the formation
he provides you a lot of different um
variations of where you can align him
within the formation and you can kind of
create a lot of hybrid groupings because
of him
and then i think he really fits our run
scheme i know a lot of people talk about
him as a receiver but i know that when i
was in denver you know we had so much
respect for him as a runner because he's
got such great uh vision
he's got really good pace as a runner
rich he's got that perfect pace where he
can really set blocks up and then he's
got more power than you think for being
a um you know what some people say a
smaller he's a shorter guy but if you
see him this guy's as packed as anybody
on the field in terms of his his play
strength and his power
so i think he's a really good fit for
how we're trying to run the football as
well um and so
you know he's you know a complete back
and and i think that um certainly gives
us a big time weapon on offense it seems
like he got a quarterback back on
defense too during james uh we did see
the house call from uh practice last
week what
uh just the the raves that i hear from
your building and from teammates and
from obviously evaluators and what he
can do
you obviously as you mentioned you're
from a defensive background and coaching
but you're a quarterback uh by trade
from your playing days
what does james do what does he do that
can help you and gives you the pieces to
move around he's a really complete
player
and i think that that's what stands out
to people in the nfl you you you notice
the complete players right away
um and he's a complete player that
happens to be
um among the rarest talents as well so
when you have talent and then rare skill
set
and then you have rare makeup
because of who he is as a person
competitor leader
then you have something that's different
and um that doesn't come around very
often and so
um there's good reason for why people
talk about him the way
people do
um because he earns it and on our
practice field last week was a good
example of it i have been a fantastic
camp
he's coming in outstanding shape full
command of our defense
he improves every day
and then just what he does for our team
from a leadership standpoint his energy
his command the way he practices the way
he prepares
the way he trains
he rubs off on any on everybody myself
included and he he has a way of bringing
out the best in people and um
love love love you know working with
this guy what do you mean but he rubs
off on you give me an example what does
that mean i think when you are with
really special players like him you know
i've been with you know a.d and ramsey
cleovan when you're around really
special players
you have a great responsibility
with that when you have people that are
as gifted as he is to
you know to really get the best out of
them and and so every day you know me
ronaldo hill derek ansley tommy
donatello all of us coaches i mean joe
lombardi our offensive coordinator we're
trying to
just maximize this guy in every way and
and live up to him um because you know
we know what he's capable of and
so we just try and pour as much into his
game as as
as we can and um i think you know
you know the type of energy and the type
of focus that he brings every single day
and as a coach that has a way of drawing
a lot out from you
you know at the same time well i mean
you know so what's your team capable of
i mean you got boza you got playmakers
all over the map right there coach and
you know i'll i'll just put it out there
i know you're probably not gonna answer
it but i'll ask it anyway um
we saw last year a team play in their
home stadium in the super bowl you got
two shots at it this year you're one of
them what's your team capable of
this well i think i think what we're you
know working towards in this camp uh and
then what we'll be working for is
becoming a complete team you know a team
that in all three phases that's capable
of winning um every game that we play
you know i think that that's uh your
goal as an nfl team or really any team
is just whoever you play that week you
feel like you can win that game and and
i feel like what's most important to us
right now is creating that identity in
all three phases of the game uh becoming
a team of teams where we really you know
know how we play understand how we play
uh why we play that way and then being
able to take that to each and every
opponent that we play and i think that
you know it's been a process in order to
get this thing off the ground but i feel
like this camp's been really competitive
and um i really like the makeup of our
team because of a lot of the guys that
you've mentioned i think what makes you
feel confident is a lot of people just
talk about your talent uh and the pieces
that you have
but then it's okay how do those pieces
come together and and can you become a
team
and i think and i know that we have that
because i know that our premium players
like you mentioned with darwin and joey
and keenan and justin and corey linsley
and all these guys that are really
special i know that they're tremendous
teammates and and that they're winners
okay you go back these guys are winners
and so um you know excited to come you
know to to get this thing off the ground
and you know rich the other thing is we
got to be ready for
the storms that are coming oh yeah
because the nfl is a really tough league
and we we you know our division alone is
really tough but you know every game
that you play there's danger you know
there's danger every game and we just
got to be ready we got to be ready for
what's coming our way and i'm confident
that we will be because a lot of those
guys that you that you've brought up
well i got to ask you this too uh
because the storm's coming as you point
out um charger fans will let you know
there's a special storm that always
appears to form for chargers fans with
about 30 seconds to go fourth quarter i
mean weird stuff
happens there's only way to put it how
do you as a new hc there
prepare for that stuff to avoid the
the usual that sometimes occurs for your
team for some reason yeah i think uh the
specifics is you have to really prepare
your practices like games and you you
pour into the practices and design them
um like games are put them through a lot
of the situational parts of the game um
and organize your walkthroughs like
games you know where you're creating
even more inventory that your guys can
draw from in terms of operating and some
of these tight situations and
um knowing the rules of the game time
score situation all that stuff and then
knowing what we like to do and and and
how we like to do it and knowing your
opponent and so there's so much that
that goes into it that factors into it
and then from just a pure game
management standpoint you know putting a
team of teams around you rich you know
it's like it can't just be a one-man
operation there's so many variables that
are happening dynamics that are changing
that's what makes the nfl special is you
surround yourself with people where you
have a system
in terms of how you operate and how you
communicate and i think that we're we're
doing our best to continue to to improve
each and every day i think these first
two games in the pre-season and then we
had a scrimmage obviously it's so far
like i feel like we're doing a good job
of that every day and um
you know getting closer to being you
know the the you know the operation that
we hope to be but uh that's all i can
say is that you you don't wake up in the
day and organize your day like real
casually you know we're really specific
really purposeful in how we do things
and
um hopefully um over time that
cumulative effect will take over where
hey we we thrive in those situations
we're not we're not like hoping
something's gonna happen we're gonna go
make it happen because we're prepared
and we're ready for it and
um you know i'm excited to to see our
leaders um
you know take off with that um as we as
we play uh real games here soon
fantastic as as i let you go you're
talking about practices i heard from uh
my colleague albert prier who was part
of watching some of your practices you
are you doing yoga you're having your
guys do yoga keep them fresh like
stretching out like this is this what's
going on here coach yeah we are um you
know i think sports performance uh our
players health uh is is at the front of
my mind each and every day okay and
making sure that uh they're ready to
prepare to train and not to pace
themselves you know the way you
uh truly improve is when you compete to
your fullest potential and so what we've
kind of done is you know
we start our practices off with an
activation period which is kind of a
two-part it's kind of a foam roll okay
with kind of you know in one station and
then like a yoga sort of ish stick you
know where you've got mats where you're
kind of doing a lot of that stuff that
um that you see taking place uh probably
on television sometimes but it's a
15-minute activation and then we have a
10-minute dynamic stretch and what that
does is it makes our our players really
they're they're ready to practice
they're warm like they're ready to go
they don't have to kind of
ease their way into practice they can
get into practice and and start playing
right away and then after practice we
have a recovery station which is a lot
of the same stuff like a recovery area
while one side of the ball is lifting uh
and so we've kind of gotten into that
rhythm and routine and our players have
got we've gotten great feedback from
them and
we've kind of partnered up with them we
started it in the spring
our sports performance team led by
anthony lomando jonathan brooks those
guys are g's and uh i feel like it's
helping our team uh become as good as it
can be so there's a photograph of joey
bosa in a tree pose because if so i'm
going to see that there'll probably be
one somewhere okay
okay and then lastly for you now that
you've been at so far you got a game you
said you got a scrimmage what's the
parking situation let's go right let's
go is there a spot for me when you're
not there a couple things going back to
the activation we may have to get that
for you before your race next year
make you you know go through that fact
the foam rolling for me is the toughest
part i'll be very honest with you i'm
52. he's not he's no complaining that i
t band is is like you could seriously
play a guitar um and have a string
lighter than my i.t band but um
but the parking parking parking okay so
i have a little bit better scouting
report for you this year thank you um
because i have actually driven to the
stadium
um so what we're trying to do is
we're going to endow a parking spot for
you
and so we're trying to do is we're
trying to get sponsors all over the
world yes to endow some spots and we're
kind of in that marketing phase i
actually have some calls that i need to
make here okay later today um but the
the rich eisen foundation parking spot
will be
um down there and so far so that you can
you know have a uh it's kind of like
it's kind of like uh the bruce wayne
when you kind of go down and so it's
kind of like down here in the caves
um so we'll make sure that you uh have a
front row speed seat down there
um so your access is is okay as good as
it gets okay because you know what my
first show from uh from from right next
door to sofi is the first sunday of the
season you know and so
you're out of town at washington um i
i'm ready is what i'm saying that's
sunday and we're like again we're in uh
the process of getting the the
endowments you know and and all these
people contributing
to these spots and uh you know justin
herbert keenan yep darwin we're all on
the phone actively recruiting brandon i
appreciate it coach i appreciate it i'll
pay it forward you know i'll pay it i'll
pay a phone thanks for the call really
appreciate it you take care thank you
you got it there's brandon staley head
coach los angeles charges
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here